With the ninth pick in the 2019 NBA draft, the Washington Wizards select Rui Hachimura...
...from Toyama, Japan and Gonzaga University.
He's the 2nd player from Japan to be drafted and this is a huge deal culturally.
There are 46 media members representing 23 outlets from Japan,...
...and it's more than any other country besides the United States.
His name means "baseball bases."
Grandfather was a huge baseball fan.
He came to Gonzaga barely speaking English, acclimated himself quickly...
...but Mark you told me this week, he's such a polite guy,...
...that he was flabbergasted early on by the fact that sometimes,...
...his teammates would lie about fouls and the score in pickup games.
Can you imagine that?
Oh, wow.
Imagine guys doing that.
That's unbelievable.
Definitely huge.
Boy, what a season he had, averaged nearly 20 points per game.
He's a very talented guy.
He can do a lot of different things.
He already has an endorsement deal...
...that's been signed because of the excitement over his starting of his NBA career...
...here in the United States.